You change your mind Like a girl, change your clothes Cause your heart and your cold Your yes and your no You're in and you're out You're up and you're down You're always right in back And it's what we fight, we break up
你像个女孩一样改变主意，换衣服，因为你的心冷漠，你的肯定和否定，你进进出出，你起起落落，你总是出尔反尔，这就是我们争吵、分手的原因。
We kiss, we make love You don't really wanna say no You don't really wanna get off Your heart and your cold Your yes and your no You're in and you're out You know you shouldn't really want to go out in the snow Your heart's in your cold, your head's in your low Your ears in your mouth, your eyes in your Viennese Street, 1866 Young Sidney Freud watches as anti-Semitic thugs
我们亲吻，我们做爱，你其实并不想说不，你其实并不想离开，你的心冷漠，你的肯定和否定，你进进出出，你知道你不该真的想去雪地里，你的心冷漠，你的头脑低沉，你的耳朵在嘴里，你的眼睛在维也纳街头，1866年，年轻的西格蒙德·弗洛伊德看着反犹太暴徒
knock his father's hat into the mud and hit him Jacob Freud picks it up, his head down, and he walks on. His eyes are dull and sad, his smile is dim-witted and dumb. He waves at them, but this wasn't the first time. Freud was ten years old. Perhaps he'd heard about these things before. Perhaps they'd even been couched in some unwritten lesson from a father to his son that this was the way things are, or the way that one handles things.
把父亲的帽子打进泥里并殴打他。雅各布·弗洛伊德捡起帽子，低着头继续走。他的眼神呆滞而悲伤，笑容显得愚钝而木讷。他向他们挥手，但这已经不是第一次了。弗洛伊德当时十岁。也许他以前就听说过这些事。也许这些事甚至被父亲以某种不成文的教诲传授给儿子，告诉他这就是现实，或者这就是处理事情的方式。
Maybe it was never spoken of. The man picking up his hat was Jacob Freud, Sigmund's father, a wool merchant who worked hard but never aimed high and never lifted his family far from poverty. He never fought back and his son would remember this moment forever, not as tragedy but as prophecy this moment forever, not as tragedy but as prophecy and as emotion and as metaphor that he would run from for his entire life. Freud's mother Amelie had other plans for her golden boy, her darling Ziggy or little Ziggy. She superstitiously and desperately believed that the universe had marked him for greatness. In her eyes it wasn't possible for him to be anything but a heroic revolutionary, a brilliant light-bringer who would turn the world on its head, and Freud was raised to believe that, not that he would, but that he had to. Years later, Freud would write about his childhood hero. I myself walked in Hannibal's footsteps, and like him, I was destined never to see Rome.
也许这从未被提起。那个捡起帽子的人是雅各布·弗洛伊德，西格蒙德的父亲，一个努力工作却从不追求高远、从未让家庭摆脱贫困的羊毛商人。他从不反抗，而他的儿子将永远记住这一刻，不是作为悲剧，而是作为预言，作为一种情感和隐喻，他将在余生中不断逃避。弗洛伊德的母亲阿梅莉对她的金童、她亲爱的齐吉或小齐吉另有打算。她迷信且绝望地相信宇宙注定他会成就伟大。在她眼中，他不可能成为除英雄般的革命者、将世界颠倒过来的杰出光明使者之外的任何人，弗洛伊德从小就被灌输这种信念，不是他会这样做，而是他必须这样做。多年后，弗洛伊德写下了关于他童年英雄的文章：我本人追随汉尼拔的足迹，像他一样，我注定永远无法看到罗马。
Hannibal and Rome symbolized in my youthful eyes the struggle between the tenacity of the Jews and the organization of the Catholic Church. But here's the thing that haunted Freud. After crossing the Alps, after the impossible march, after defeating the Roman armies, Hannibal stopped. He stood up the gates of Rome itself and hesitated. Victory within reach and he couldn't take it. Even in Freud's dreams he could never enter Rome. The passivity, the fear, the conflict at superior forces, it would define everything. Freud would attach these forces to anti-Semitism and Christianity and the larger cultural forces where he felt he was not allowed
汉尼拔和罗马在我年轻的眼中象征着犹太人的坚韧与天主教会的组织之间的斗争。但困扰弗洛伊德的是这一点：在翻越阿尔卑斯山、完成不可能的行军、击败罗马军队之后，汉尼拔停下了。他站在罗马城门前犹豫了。胜利触手可及，他却无法夺取。即使在弗洛伊德的梦中，他也永远无法进入罗马。这种被动、恐惧、面对强大力量时的冲突，将定义他的一切。弗洛伊德会将这些力量与反犹太主义、基督教以及更广泛的文化力量联系起来，他感到自己不被允许
and the reasons that he was not allowed to go into these spaces. However, missing the point of his own system of thought, he would not ever connect them intelligently or accurately to his own upbringing. In psychodynamic thinking, which Freud would invent and then strangle in its crib when he needed to, we learn what makes us lovable from the parent of the opposite sex. But we learn how to be in the world, or our coping style, from the parent of the same sex. From his mother, greatness equaled love. From his father, Freud learned to submit and conform and avoid any type of conflict. This extreme passivity, Freud absorbed, made him repress every competitive or aggressive impulse. Freud would never connect the ambivalence between
以及他不被允许进入这些空间的理由。然而，他忽略了自己思想体系的重点，他从未将这些与自己的成长经历进行明智或准确的联系。在弗洛伊德发明并随后在需要时扼杀的心理动力学思想中，我们从异性父母那里学习什么让我们可爱。但我们从同性父母那里学习如何在这个世界上生存，或者我们的应对方式。从母亲那里，伟大等于爱。从父亲那里，弗洛伊德学会了顺从、妥协并避免任何形式的冲突。这种极端的被动，弗洛伊德吸收了，使他压抑了每一个竞争或攻击的冲动。弗洛伊德从未将这种矛盾心理与
the need to hide from God and the need to be God, or the desire to disappear and not have to fight with the need to fight. The inability to handle anger, whether or not we handle it in an outward way or an internal way, is the same thing. And Freud would never realize that even though he handled his phobias, his neuroses, whatever you want to call them, I would call them an avoidance of an emotional arc. Differently from his father, that he was still ruled for his entire life by the same thing. That had ruled Jacob. So naturally, this repressed aggression became the cornerstone of his psychology, and we diagnose in others what we can't admit in ourselves. As Joseph Campbell would
躲避上帝的需要与成为上帝的需要，或者消失的欲望与不必战斗的欲望，以及战斗的需要联系起来。处理愤怒的能力，无论我们是以向外还是向内的方式处理，本质上是一样的。弗洛伊德永远不会意识到，尽管他处理了自己的恐惧症、神经症，无论你怎么称呼它们，我会称之为对情感弧线的回避。与他父亲不同的是，他一生仍然被统治雅各布的同样事物所统治。因此，自然地，这种被压抑的攻击性成为了他心理学的基石，我们在他人身上诊断出我们无法在自己身上承认的东西。正如约瑟夫·坎贝尔
later point out, Freud was fishing while he sat on a whale. Freud prided himself on being bold, revolutionary. Read his letters. It's all self-deception. When he disagreed with his friends or mentors, he didn't argue for compromise. And rarely did he ever confront them. Oftentimes, he developed a very deep internal self-loathing while appearing overly facile, supplicatory, and sort of like negotiating with them, or complimenting them, while he hated them. Most of the time, he simply cut them off. Jung, Adler, Rank. First they were worshipped, and then they were discarded. Adler, Rank. First they were worshipped and then they were discarded. Brewer, Fleece, Charcot. They were adopted fathers until they disappointed him. Take his golden boy period, you know, with Carl Jung. They were discussing a patient's dream. Jung offers a different interpretation of the dream than his own
后来指出的那样，弗洛伊德坐在鲸鱼上钓鱼。弗洛伊德以大胆、革命自居。读读他的信件吧。那全是自欺欺人。当他与朋友或导师意见不合时，他从不主张妥协。他也很少与他们对质。通常，他会产生一种非常深刻的内在自我厌恶，同时表现得过于圆滑、卑微，似乎在与他们谈判，或者恭维他们，而内心却憎恨他们。大多数时候，他只是切断了与他们的联系。荣格、阿德勒、兰克。起初他们被崇拜，然后被抛弃。布洛伊尔、弗利斯、沙可。他们曾是领养的父亲，直到他们让他失望。看看他的金童时期，你知道，和卡尔·荣格在一起。他们正在讨论一个病人的梦。荣格提出了与他自己不同的梦境解释
dream, right? It's Jung's dream. And Freud turns white and he shakes and he faints and he falls to the floor. And he tells Jung that this interpretation cannot be true. Freud tells Jung that both the contra interpretation of his dream and the bog bodies that they're about to see the exhibit of in Vienna that Jung has mentioned mean that Freud, that Jung has a death wish against Freud. Simply because Jung had a willingness to think for himself that would kill the image of perfection that Freud needed to feel lovable. This is someone who throughout their entire career, if you want to sit with this idea that we become lovable from the parent of the opposite sex, meaning not necessarily what makes us lovable all the time, but a lot of times what informs our purpose.
梦，对吧？那是荣格的梦。弗洛伊德脸色苍白，颤抖着，晕倒在地板上。他告诉荣格，这种解释不可能是真的。弗洛伊德告诉荣格，无论是对他梦境的相反解释，还是荣格提到的他们在维也纳即将看到的沼泽木乃伊展览，都意味着弗洛伊德认为荣格对他有杀意。仅仅因为荣格有独立思考的意愿，这会摧毁弗洛伊德为了感到可爱所需要的完美形象。这是一个在整个职业生涯中，如果你想接受这个观点，即我们从异性父母那里变得可爱，这意味着不一定是什么让我们一直可爱，但很多时候是什么塑造了我们的目标。
To be an artist, to be an innovator, to be a discoverer, to see through the lives of society, to be a hard worker, to be somebody who conforms to the rules as a point of order, as a point of pride, whatever that is, often is at odds with the way we learn to be in the world from the parent of the same sex. We learn what makes our purpose from the parent of the opposite sex, but how to be in the world, or what our coping style is from the parent of the same sex and a lot of times especially if you're a wounded healer like most therapists these things are at odds sometimes we learn to be over antagonistic to from the parent of the same sex or we learn as our coping style
成为艺术家、创新者、发现者、看穿社会生活、成为努力工作的人、成为作为秩序点、作为骄傲点而遵守规则的人，无论那是什么，往往与我们从同性父母那里学习如何在这个世界上生存的方式相冲突。我们从异性父母那里学习什么构成了我们的目标，但如何在这个世界上生存，或者我们的应对风格是什么，则来自同性父母，很多时候，特别是如果你像大多数治疗师一样是一个受伤的治疗者，这些事情有时是矛盾的，有时我们学会了对同性父母过度对抗，或者我们学会了作为我们的应对风格
to performatively seek victimhood or the lost cause of the great person that will ultimately be undone or to simply shut down and then cry out and receive help from a from a parent but Freud needed to be the most brilliant person in the room, but he also couldn't really fight with anyone and So he had to continue to back up until he had an all-encompassing system of understanding where his brilliance preceded him and his authority was presupposed by everyone because he couldn't have conflict. Cut to Vienna 1844. Freud's first and last love wasn't a woman or an idea, it was cocaine. He starts researching it in 1884
表演性地寻求受害者身份，或者最终会失败的伟大人物的失落事业，或者干脆关闭自己，然后哭喊着从父母那里获得帮助。但弗洛伊德需要成为房间里最聪明的人，但他又真的无法与任何人争吵，所以他不得不不断后退，直到他拥有了一个包罗万象的理解体系，他的才华先于他，他的权威被所有人预设，因为他不能有冲突。切回维也纳1844年。弗洛伊德的第一个也是最后一个爱人不是女人或某种思想，而是可卡因。他从1884年开始研究它
and convinced that he found this miracle cure. His colleague Karl Kohler is searching for this topical anesthetic crucial for eye surgery in an era before general anesthesia. When you cut on people in an area in a time before antibiotics and a time before anesthesia to do surgery, they tend to do something that is sort of inconvenient for the surgeon, like be awake and squirm around and have involuntary reactions to pain. Freud suggests cocaine, and it works. It was one of the decade's biggest medical discoveries.
并确信他找到了这种奇迹般的疗法。他的同事卡尔·科勒正在寻找这种在全身麻醉时代之前的眼科手术中至关重要的局部麻醉剂。当你在抗生素和麻醉出现之前的时代对人进行手术时，他们往往会做一些对外科医生来说很不方便的事情，比如保持清醒、扭动身体并对疼痛产生不自主的反应。弗洛伊德建议使用可卡因，结果奏效了。这是那个十年最伟大的医学发现之一。
But what does Freud do? First he congratulates Kohler, even though he feels like it's stolen while he's visiting his fiancé. So he plants rumors that Kohler stole the discovery from his notes, even though it was freely given, and Freud probably didn't understand the implications of that discovery when it happens, or his own insight. And Kohler also freely gave Freud credit, even though he published the paper. The slander follows Kohler's ophthalmology career to America for the rest of his life, another discarded father figure that Jung would collect, just like another discarded son figure
但弗洛伊德做了什么？起初他祝贺科勒，尽管他在拜访未婚妻时觉得这被偷走了。于是他散布谣言说科勒从他的笔记中窃取了这一发现，尽管这是自由提供的，而且弗洛伊德在事情发生时可能并不理解该发现的含义，或者他自己的洞察力。科勒也自由地将功劳归于弗洛伊德，尽管是他发表了论文。这种诽谤跟随科勒的眼科职业生涯到美国，伴随他余生，这是荣格收集的另一个被抛弃的父亲形象，就像另一个被抛弃的儿子形象
discarded father figure that Jung would collect just like another discarded son figure that he would never ultimately be able to craft the perfect son, just like he could never craft himself into the perfect father. And this starts this pattern. Freud courts father figures and then he destroys them. And it also starts Freud's solution to every problem for a while, which is cocaine. solution to every problem for a while which is cocaine. Freud starts, he switches careers at this point. There will not be a bigger discovery in surgery. There can't be. Kohler's taken it and so Freud enters neurology and he begins treating depressed patients by injecting them with cocaine and asking them how they feel and typically they feel great. So he publishes triumphantly. Cocaine became the first wonderful you know revelation in surgery but I had to leave that field because I am the darling and precious Ziggy who is the most brilliant and now I
被抛弃的父亲形象，荣格会收集它，就像另一个被抛弃的儿子形象，他最终永远无法塑造出完美的儿子，就像他永远无法将自己塑造出完美的父亲一样。这开启了这个模式。弗洛伊德追求父亲形象，然后摧毁他们。这也开启了弗洛伊德一段时间内解决所有问题的方案，那就是可卡因。弗洛伊德开始，他在这一点上转换了职业。手术中不会有比这更大的发现。不可能有。科勒已经拿走了它，所以弗洛伊德进入了神经学，他开始通过注射可卡因来治疗抑郁症患者，并询问他们的感受，通常他们感觉很好。于是他得意洋洋地发表了。可卡因成为了手术中第一个美妙的启示，但我不得不离开那个领域，因为我是那个最聪明、珍贵的小齐吉，现在我
can never be known for that so I have to bring this to another field. But several patients get addicted to Kotang like one does and then in one of his close friends Ernst von Fleischel he dies horribly. And Freud never publishes objective research again because when he takes a risk with a real study about a real drug in an objective way it hurts him, he becomes disgraced and Freud never publishes in that way he transforms himself into something different that is inherently subjective, inherently
再也不能因此而闻名，所以我必须把这个带到另一个领域。但几个病人像人们常做的那样对可卡因上瘾，然后在他的一位密友恩斯特·冯·弗莱舍尔身上，他死得很惨。弗洛伊德再也没有发表过客观的研究，因为当他以客观的方式对一种真正的药物进行真正的研究时，他冒了险，这伤害了他，他变得声名狼藉，弗洛伊德再也没有那样发表过文章，他将自己转变成了一种本质上是主观的、本质上是
slippery beneath the rules of empiricism. Dr. Frederick Cruz's book on this, Freud Making of an Illusion, is a good one. I've said before on the blog he was a pen pal of mine before his death and we had the same enemy so I enjoyed corresponding with him quite a bit. Props to him, you should read the book. A lot of the newer work on Freud, it's probably the best new work on Freud because even the best biographies of Freud didn't have the information that we have now, simply because a lot of these things were still covered up by the descendants of Freud until relatively
在经验主义规则下难以捉摸的东西。弗雷德里克·克鲁兹博士关于此的书《弗洛伊德：幻觉的制造》是一本好书。我之前在博客上说过，他在去世前是我的笔友，我们有共同的敌人，所以我很喜欢和他通信。向他致敬，你应该读读这本书。关于弗洛伊德的许多较新的作品，这可能是关于弗洛伊德最好的新作品，因为即使是弗洛伊德最好的传记也没有我们现在拥有的信息，仅仅因为很多这些事情直到相对
recently. It's a good book, I won't opine too much, but I do want to give sort of credit to a source since these aren't entirely academic things. After this, Freud retreats into the secret workings of the inner mind, where empirical embarrassment can't really follow you because you just make things up and then when you make things up people can't tell you that you're wrong or if they do you get to tell them that you're wrong too and there's not like a dead guy who was addicted to cocaine that follows you around in a way that sort of indicates that like
最近才被弗洛伊德的后代掩盖。这是一本好书，我不会发表太多意见，但我确实想给出一个来源的功劳，因为这些并不完全是学术性的东西。在此之后，弗洛伊德退缩到内心世界的秘密运作中，在那里经验主义的尴尬无法真正跟随你，因为你只是编造东西，然后当你编造东西时，人们无法告诉你你是错的，或者如果他们这样做了，你也可以告诉他们他们也是错的，而且没有像一个对可卡因上瘾的死人那样以某种方式跟随你，表明
you didn't know what you were doing. So for 10 to 15 years when Freud's tolerance is building to cocaine, he switches to wine for withdrawals and he writes about spending weekends with his friend Marsala while he's using wine to come down off of the cocaine benders. Don't drink Marsala wine, it's gross. Don't even cook with it. There's no Marsala section at the wine store for a reason and if you find it in the cooking store and you make chicken marsala I don't know just anyway. Freud while he's high on cocaine becomes convinced that his personal theories explain everything that everyone must accept them and that he alone possesses this key to understanding the human psyche which if you've ever been around somebody who's doing cocaine is
你不知道自己在做什么。所以有10到15年，当弗洛伊德对可卡因的耐受性增强时，他改用葡萄酒来戒断，他写道，当他使用葡萄酒来缓解可卡因狂欢后的戒断反应时，他与朋友马萨拉度过了周末。不要喝马萨拉酒，它很难喝。甚至不要用它做饭。酒类商店里没有马萨拉区是有原因的，如果你在烹饪店里找到它并做了鸡肉马萨拉，我不知道，总之。弗洛伊德在吸食可卡因时变得确信他的个人理论解释了一切，每个人都必须接受它们，并且只有他一个人拥有理解人类心灵的钥匙，如果你曾经和吸食可卡因的人在一起，这是
pretty typical about what it does. Usually your thought process is I have the best idea in the world, it's that I'm going to start a restaurant and it's gonna be the best restaurant in the world because the food there will be the best food ever and everyone will love it and this is wonderful and you should do it with me. And also I just noticed that I can smell evil and you and me man, like you and me can tell evil and also have the best ideas we're gonna make the most money ever. That tends to be what it does to people who work food service but when it comes to the founder of modern psychology it worked the same way. Because your heart's in your cold, your yes and your no, you're in and you're out, you're up and you're down Enter Jean Martin Charcot. So cut to Paris, 1885. Charcot is staging this show, a circus.
很典型的表现。通常你的思维过程是：我有一个世界上最好的主意，那就是我要开一家餐馆，它将是世界上最好的餐馆，因为那里的食物将是有史以来最好的食物，每个人都会喜欢它，这太棒了，你应该和我一起做。而且我刚刚注意到我可以闻到邪恶，你和我，伙计，就像你和我可以分辨邪恶，并且有最好的主意，我们将赚到最多的钱。这往往是它对从事餐饮服务的人所做的事情，但当谈到现代心理学的创始人时，它的作用方式是一样的。因为你的心冷漠，你的肯定和否定，你进进出出，你起起落落。让·马丁·沙可登场。所以切回巴黎，1885年。沙可正在上演这场表演，一场马戏。
Traumatized women, hysterics, as they were called then. They perform their symptoms for the medical students and Charcot hypnotizes them with electricity, sometimes blinding lights, loud sounds, eyelid manipulation, he rubs the eyes. He can make symptoms appear and disappear at will. He's making these women perform to show his magical powers and Freud is watching. This isn't therapy. Charcot believes that hysteria comes from defective genes, that these women can't be cured only displayed, and they're kept against their will. They're committed and they're just continued to be traumatized by Charcot for theatrical effect. Freud's peers are kind of disgusted because this isn't normal or
受创伤的女性，歇斯底里症患者，当时就是这么称呼她们的。她们为医学生表演她们的症状，沙可有时用电、有时用刺眼的灯光、巨大的声音、眼睑操纵来催眠她们，他揉搓眼睛。他可以随意让症状出现和消失。他让这些女性表演来展示他的魔力，而弗洛伊德正在观看。这不是治疗。沙可认为歇斯底里症来自有缺陷的基因，这些女性无法被治愈，只能被展示，而且她们是被违背意愿关押的。她们被关进精神病院，并继续被沙可为了戏剧效果而创伤。弗洛伊德的同龄人有点反感，因为这在当时并不正常或
typical for the time and this theatrical abuse is absurd even for the 1880s but Freud is mesmerized. Here is this technique that can't be disproven and here is this power over the human mind that can be used to impress. And he sees patients under hypnosis describing childhood sexual abuse, but where Charcot sees genetic defects that are causing these things, Freud sees this opportunity. What if trauma causes hysteria? What if he can cure it by uncovering repressed memories of the trauma in the same way with the
典型，这种戏剧性的虐待即使在1880年代也是荒谬的，但弗洛伊德被迷住了。这里有一种无法被反驳的技术，这里有一种可以用来给人留下深刻印象的对人类心灵的控制力。他看到在催眠下的病人描述童年性虐待，但沙可看到的是导致这些事情的基因缺陷，而弗洛伊德看到了这个机会。如果创伤导致歇斯底里症呢？如果他能通过揭开创伤的压抑记忆来治愈它，用同样的方式，用
same showmanship with the same ability to see underneath society and preempt these forces that give him a power over the world in a way that normal people can't see. Back in Vienna Freud discovers hypnosis is hard when the patients aren't captive, like prisoners in cages brought out by staff in order to be conditioned to perform, so he invents something better, free association, which is completely subjective, 100% effective because it's only Freud is able to decode it, surprise surprise he's always right. He partners with Joseph Breuer studying the patient Anna Oh and Breuer notices that she experiences catharsis when she is
同样的表演技巧，同样的看穿社会并先发制人地利用那些赋予他一种普通人无法看到的对世界权力的力量的能力。回到维也纳，弗洛伊德发现当病人不是囚犯时，催眠很难，不像被工作人员带出来以适应表演的笼中囚犯，所以他发明了更好的东西，自由联想，这是完全主观的，100%有效，因为只有弗洛伊德能够解码它，惊喜惊喜，他总是对的。他与约瑟夫·布洛伊尔合作研究病人安娜·欧，布洛伊尔注意到当她
expressing emotions about traumatic memory. Her symptoms improve and Freud watches and then he agrees and then decides that Breuer is too afraid of sexuality later because Brewer's not willing to follow Freud into the the brute cause of every problem being sexual. And because Freud can't replicate Brewer's empathetic technique of relating to the patient and making them feel something like, I don't know, comfortable or heard or feel something like, I don't know, comfortable or heard or reciprocally participating in the own experience of their treatment or at least the interpretation of the memories in their life, he declares that Brewer's wrong. And where Brewer's patients took trauma, accounts at face value,
表达关于创伤记忆的情绪时，她会经历宣泄。她的症状有所改善，弗洛伊德看着，然后他同意，然后决定布洛伊尔后来太害怕性了，因为布洛伊尔不愿意跟随弗洛伊德进入每个问题的根本原因都是性的领域。而且因为弗洛伊德无法复制布洛伊尔那种与病人建立联系并让他们感到某种东西，比如，我不知道，舒适或被倾听，或者感到某种东西，比如，我不知道，舒适或被倾听，或互惠地参与他们治疗的自身体验，或者至少是他们生活中记忆的解释，他宣布布洛伊尔是错的。而布洛伊尔的病人接受创伤叙述的表面价值，
Freud decides that actually they're lying but only he knows what the lies mean and why they're there. Those abuse memories actually they're unconscious fantasies. So at first Freud does consider under Brewer that a whole lot of really rich, noble people in Vienna are sexually abusing their children, people who are well thought of and have these careers, but then later he decides, no, that's just wrong, children are inherently sexual.
弗洛伊德决定实际上她们在撒谎，但只有他知道谎言意味着什么以及它们为什么在那里。那些虐待记忆实际上是无意识的幻想。所以起初弗洛伊德确实在布洛伊尔的指导下认为维也纳有很多非常有钱、高贵的人在性虐待他们的孩子，那些被认为很好并有这些职业的人，但后来他决定，不，那是错的，孩子本质上是性的。
So it's sort of up for debate. How much of this decision was practical because Freud was Jewish and thought well if I can start saying that a whole bunch of and also poor so like if I start saying a whole bunch of like really rich Austrians and Germans basically have sex with their children secretly and then lie about it and traumatize their kids maybe this was not something that practically could be done at that point. Other people feel, other historians feel like it was more just sort of a direction that Freud wanted to go because it was definitely the easy route, you know, for lots of reasons. So what Freud
所以这有点值得商榷。这个决定有多少是实际的，因为弗洛伊德是犹太人，心想，好吧，如果我开始说一大堆，而且也很穷，所以如果我开始说一大堆像非常有钱的奥地利人和德国人基本上秘密地与他们的孩子发生性关系，然后撒谎并创伤他们的孩子，也许这不是在那个时候可以实际做的事情。其他人觉得，其他历史学家觉得这更多是弗洛伊德想要走的方向，因为这绝对是简单的路线，你知道，出于很多原因。所以弗洛伊德
decides is that children are inherently sexual, they want to be abused, they want to have sex with the parent, and because they want that they go ahead and invent it in their mind and then the abuse never really happened. And so what needs to happen is that we need to analyze these people who we're talking about experiences that probably happened to them. And when we talk to them somehow they'll figure out that the root of their sexual abuse was actually their own desire as an infant or something and then they get cured. I'm still not sure what the point of psychoanalysis actually is. Please don't email me. Brewer had the humility to point out,
决定的是，孩子本质上是性的，他们想要被虐待，他们想要与父母发生性关系，因为他们想要那个，所以他们就在脑海中编造了它，然后虐待从未真正发生过。所以需要发生的是，我们需要分析这些我们正在谈论的经历可能确实发生在他们身上的人。当我们和他们交谈时，他们会以某种方式发现他们性虐待的根源实际上是他们作为婴儿的欲望或类似的东西，然后他们就被治愈了。我仍然不确定心理分析的重点到底是什么。请不要给我发电子邮件。布洛伊尔有谦逊指出，
you know, that he wanted to learn from patients. But for Freud, authority was the point to be the father the paterfamilias that the patient started to listen to to understand themselves in a way that Freud's own father had never manifested authority and never listened to him and so now he Freud could tell the patients what they really felt and what they really wanted even they're over their own objections to what their feelings were or memories or sexuality in a lot of cases really anything about them Freud understood better than they did Brewer wrote Freud is a man given to absolutes and exclusive formulations and this is a psychical need in my opinion which leads to
你知道，他想向病人学习。但对弗洛伊德来说，权威才是重点，成为父亲，成为一家之主，病人开始倾听，以一种弗洛伊德自己的父亲从未表现出权威且从未倾听他的方式来理解自己，所以现在他弗洛伊德可以告诉病人他们真正感受到了什么以及他们真正想要什么，即使是在他们对自己感受或记忆或性行为的反对意见之上，在很多情况下，真的关于他们的任何事情，弗洛伊德都比他们自己更了解。布洛伊尔写道，弗洛伊德是一个倾向于绝对和排他性表述的人，在我看来这是一种心理需求，这导致了
excessive generalization something we might call now reductionism. The translation the cocaine is making him think that one weird theory explains everything multiple times even when those weird theories contradict on different benders of cocaine and marsala wine. Brewer had been more than a colleague though, he'd lent Freud money, he referred patients, he welcomed him into his home. He, on his own, you know, by his own admission was sort of trying to be a good father to get his wayward disciple on a good path because even though Freud's mother expected him to be brilliant, Freud was brilliant. He was an incredibly good writer, he was an incredibly good salesman for his ideas, a
过度概括，我们现在可能称之为还原论。翻译一下，可卡因让他认为一个奇怪的理论可以解释一切，即使在可卡因和马萨拉酒的不同狂欢中，这些奇怪的理论相互矛盾。布洛伊尔不仅仅是一个同事，他借给弗洛伊德钱，他推荐病人，他欢迎他进入他的家。他，他自己，你知道，按照他自己的承认，有点试图成为一个好父亲，让他的任性弟子走上一条好的道路，因为尽管弗洛伊德的母亲期望他变得聪明，但弗洛伊德确实很聪明。他是一个非常好的作家，他是一个非常好的思想推销员，一个
good metaphor smith, even though he failed to understand metaphors, he wrote them fairly well and he also was a genius in a way that many people during this time weren't, and that did give him the sort of passive power through speech, through talking, over patients, over providers, and over the readers of his work. So Freud repays Brewer's generosity with slander, claiming that Brewer abandoned Anna O due to fear of sexuality. And as Yale historian Peter Gay notes in his book, classic case of ingratitude the resentment of a proud debtor against his benefactor. So exit Brewer and enter William Fleece,
好的隐喻制造者，尽管他未能理解隐喻，但他写得相当好，而且他也是一个天才，以一种当时许多人所没有的方式，这确实给了他通过言语、通过交谈，对病人、对提供者以及对他的作品读者的被动权力。所以弗洛伊德用诽谤来回报布洛伊尔的慷慨，声称布洛伊尔由于对性的恐惧而抛弃了安娜·欧。正如耶鲁大学历史学家彼得·盖伊在他的书中所指出的，这是忘恩负义的经典案例，一个骄傲的债务人对他恩人的怨恨。所以布洛伊尔退出，威廉·弗利斯登场，
a much poorer substitute for a therapist, psychiatrist, neurologist, surgeon, whatever, batted all of them, and also a much poorer excuse for a father. Fleece is a magnificently weird character in an era where people are doing things like cutting off different parts of the body to see if insanity come from them. Like there's a guy that pulls out teeth for a while and he's like, maybe there's bacteria in the teeth and the bacteria go to the brain and that's the reason why people are crazy
一个糟糕得多的治疗师、精神科医生、神经科医生、外科医生，无论什么，都尝试过，也是一个糟糕得多的父亲借口。弗利斯是一个极其奇怪的人物，在一个人们正在做诸如切断身体不同部位来看看疯狂是否来自它们的事情的时代。比如有一个人有一段时间拔牙，他说，也许牙齿里有细菌，细菌进入大脑，这就是人们疯狂的原因
and that crazy people, I'm using shorthand to them, I'm not calling them crazy, but like mental patients during this time, maybe the reason why they have these issues is if you pull their teeth out. When you pull your teeth out, they don't really bite as hard, so maybe they're better. Assumptions like that were relatively normal for a minute.
而那些疯子，我是在用速记法称呼他们，我不是在叫他们疯子，但像那个时代的精神病人，也许他们有这些问题的原因是如果你把他们的牙齿拔掉。当你把牙齿拔掉时，他们就不会咬得那么厉害了，所以也许他们会好起来。像那样的假设在当时相对正常了一会儿。
So this is in that world, but it still is strange even for the time. Fleece believes that if you cut the nose off, pull bones out of the interior of the nostrils, and then sew the nose back on, that that will stop masturbation because the urge to do masturbation comes from the nose, and that when you stop masturbating that cures all physical and emotional problems. By the connections between these things are magic. I've read Fleece. He believes these things to be self-evident in a way that he doesn't explain or cite sources because whatever. Anyway, this appeals to Freud because it's a very reductive description for behavior
所以这是在那个世界里，但即使在当时它仍然很奇怪。弗利斯认为，如果你切掉鼻子，从鼻孔内部拔出骨头，然后把鼻子缝回去，那将停止手淫，因为手淫的冲动来自鼻子，而当你停止手淫时，那会治愈所有身体和情感问题。通过这些事物之间的联系是魔法。我读过弗利斯。他认为这些事情是不言而喻的，以至于他没有解释或引用来源，因为无论如何。总之，这吸引了弗洛伊德，因为它是一个非常简化的行为描述
and it also goes back to sexuality. Freud loves at this point telling patients that their problem comes from repressed sexuality and masturbation or some relationship between those two things. And so he overlooks these wildly incompatible theories about biology even for the time, surgery. And some biographers think that Freud was maybe in love with fleece a little bit more
而且它也回到了性。弗洛伊德在这一点上喜欢告诉病人他们的问题来自被压抑的性欲和手淫，或者这两者之间的某种关系。所以他忽略了这些关于生物学、手术的极其不相容的理论，即使在当时也是如此。一些传记作者认为弗洛伊德可能有点爱上了弗利斯
so than just as a father figure that there was a bisexual element to his I don't know the letters between them are very very intense I'll say that. Freud is this meticulous record keeper and he mysteriously doesn't save any of fleece's replies we don't have them we only have Freud's letters to fleece and so here comes incident, the falling out that would continue to happen with all of Freud's fathers and all of Freud's sons, where Freud refers this patient to Fleece for nasal surgery because she admits to masturbating, so that must be the reason why she has every medical and psychological condition that she also is complaining of, and that patient nearly bleeds
不仅仅是作为一个父亲形象，他们之间有一种双性恋的元素，我不知道，他们之间的信件非常非常强烈，我会这么说。弗洛伊德是一个一丝不苟的记录保存者，他神秘地没有保存任何弗利斯的回复，我们没有它们，我们只有弗洛伊德写给弗利斯的信，所以这里发生了事件，那种会继续发生在弗洛伊德所有父亲和所有弗洛伊德儿子身上的决裂，弗洛伊德把这个病人推荐给弗利斯进行鼻部手术，因为她承认手淫，所以那一定是她抱怨的所有医疗和心理状况的原因，而那个病人几乎流血
to death. This letter is horrifying, I won't read it at length, but it is sycophantic and bizarre. Seven times she almost bleeds to death. And when the doctor investigates to find out why she has continued to bleed from her nose is almost dying, they have another surgeon who's local, Fleece has gone home, and he pokes at the wound and figures out that there is literally half a meter of gauze that you use to stop bleeding during surgery on noses that you don't need to be doing to stop patients from masturbating that Fleece has stuffed in the nose, forgot about, sewed the nose back on and left inside. So Freud's letter to Fleece says, at the moment of the foreign body it was came out and everything became clear to me and I felt sick and
致死。这封信令人毛骨悚然，我不会全文朗读，但它是谄媚和怪异的。她七次差点流血致死。当医生调查发现为什么她继续从鼻子里流血并几乎要死时，他们有另一位当地的外科医生，弗利斯已经回家了，他戳了戳伤口，发现里面确实有半米长的纱布，那是你在鼻部手术期间用来止血的，你根本不需要做这种手术来阻止病人手淫，弗利斯把它塞进鼻子里，忘了它，把鼻子缝回去并留在里面。所以弗洛伊德写给弗利斯的信说，在异物出来的那一刻，一切都对我变得清晰了，我感到恶心，并且
she had been packed I fled the room and I drank a bottle of water and felt miserable. But then incredibly Freud defendsends fleece. He says these accidents happened to the most unfortunate and circumspect surgeons, that absolutely no one would consider you a negligent for having left half a meter of cotton balled up in this woman's face while you're cutting her nose open to try and stop her from masturbating and other doctors refuse to support fleeces and competence. This is wildly strange. You don't really have to be a surgeon to understand how bad you have to be at surgery to stuff something that is at least, at least medical gauze, that's like four to six inches here compressed into the
她被填塞了，我逃离了房间，我喝了一瓶水，感觉很痛苦。但随后令人难以置信的是，弗洛伊德为弗利斯辩护。他说这些事故发生在最不幸和谨慎的外科医生身上，绝对没有人会认为你因为在切开这个女人的鼻子试图阻止她手淫时，把半米长的棉花球留在她的脸上而疏忽，而其他医生拒绝支持弗利斯的无能。这极其奇怪。你真的不需要成为一名外科医生就能理解你在手术中必须有多糟糕，才能把至少，至少是医用纱布，那大约有四到六英寸长，压缩进
nasal cavity and then forget that you did. No one at the time supports Fleece, he loses all respect. Freud begs Fleece to continue to understand that no one's angry with him even when everyone is and the letters are really weird. Again we only have Freud's, we don't have Fleece's. It looks based on Freud's response like Fleece is responding, like wanting more support which I don't even know how it's possible. It looks like he's asking Freud to intercede and get the support of other doctors to say that he didn't do anything wrong which means that he probably knows that he did. Anyway, the
鼻腔，然后忘了你做了这件事。当时没有人支持弗利斯，他失去了所有的尊重。弗洛伊德恳求弗利斯继续理解没有人对他生气，即使每个人都生气，这些信件真的很奇怪。同样，我们只有弗洛伊德的，我们没有弗利斯的。根据弗洛伊德的回应，看起来弗利斯正在回应，想要更多的支持，我甚至不知道这怎么可能。看起来他是在要求弗洛伊德进行调解，并获得其他医生的支持，说他没有做错任何事，这意味着他可能知道他做了。总之，
scandal eventually ruins Fleece because people talk about him that aren't Freud or maybe Freud do. He probably is kind of disingenuous that he definitely throws Fleece under the bus when it's cool. Who knows who did it initially? Probably the surgeon that operated. And so now Freud learned his final lesson you never be the son again from now on you are the father and so one by one he collects people like Carl Jung, Otto Rank, Alfred Adler and one by one you know Freud tells them that they are his successor and that they will carry the fire into the future of all of his ideas and that they are superior to all of their colleagues and same script and
丑闻最终毁了弗利斯，因为人们谈论他，而不是弗洛伊德，或者也许弗洛伊德做了。他可能有点虚伪，当情况很酷时，他绝对把弗利斯扔到了公共汽车下。谁知道最初是谁做的？可能是操作的外科医生。所以现在弗洛伊德学到了他最后的教训，你永远不要再做儿子了，从现在开始你是父亲，所以他一个接一个地收集像卡尔·荣格、奥托·兰克、阿尔弗雷德·阿德勒这样的人，一个接一个地，你知道，弗洛伊德告诉他们他们是他的继任者，他们将把火炬带入他所有思想的未来，他们优于他们所有的同事，同样的剧本，
then one by one they develop their own ideas and one by one he cuts them off for pistol loyalty because he's threatened by anything that diverges from total loyalty to everything that he says which a lot of times is not consistent with the thing that he says next but that doesn't matter and by the time he reaches New York, only the talentless and the obsequious remain. He names them his secret committee, he gives them golden rings with sexually symbolic cameos, he models it on the secret society that he likes, and he's chased off by that point anyone who has any sort of intellectual ability like Freud was attracted to charisma and He did collect people who tended to be very
然后一个接一个地他们发展出自己的想法，一个接一个地他因为手枪忠诚而切断了他们，因为他受到任何偏离对他所说的一切完全忠诚的东西的威胁，这在很多时候与他接下来所说的不一致，但这并不重要，当他到达纽约时，只剩下无能和谄媚的人。他任命他们为他的秘密委员会，他给他们带有性象征浮雕的金戒指，他以他喜欢的秘密社团为蓝本，到那时他已经赶走了任何有某种智力能力的人，就像弗洛伊德被魅力所吸引，他确实收集了往往非常
Charismatic effective smart, you know he he was brilliant himself he was attracted but also threatened by other people's brilliance, especially men and attracted but also threatened by other people's brilliance, especially men. And by the time that he's in New York there is no one left that you could describe as anyone other than a complete Midwit intellectual lightweight in his inner circle. Except for maybe Anna Freud who is sort of compromised from being his daughter but you know she's not terribly creative. I don't think that's an intellectual inability. She did get Freud's brilliance, but I do think that her legacy to Freud as a myth is part of the reason why she basically is, up until her death, changing his correspondence,
有魅力、有效、聪明的人，你知道，他自己很聪明，他被吸引，但也受到其他人聪明才智的威胁，特别是男人，被吸引但也受到其他人聪明才智的威胁，特别是男人。当他在纽约时，他的核心圈子里没有剩下任何可以被描述为除完全的中庸、智力轻量级之外的任何人。除了可能安娜·弗洛伊德，她因为是他的女儿而有点妥协，但你知道她不是特别有创造力。我不认为那是一种智力上的无能。她确实得到了弗洛伊德的才华，但我确实认为她作为神话对弗洛伊德的遗产是她基本上直到去世都在改变他的通信的原因之一，
lying to biographers about what's in archives, because she has a loyalty to keeping this person's legend around that diverges from the history of who he was and what he said. And these secret committees, as Freud calls them, they meet in the shadows, they plot against anyone who deviates from the doctrine, they literally destroy careers of patients and other providers who disagree with them. And one dissenting analyst is so destroyed by their rumors that he kills himself and he begs Freud's forgiveness, which Freud refuses to give him.
对传记作者撒谎关于档案里有什么，因为她有一种忠诚，要保持这个人的传奇，这与他是谁以及他说了什么的真实历史相背离。而这些秘密委员会，正如弗洛伊德所称的那样，他们在阴影中会面，他们密谋反对任何偏离教义的人，他们确实摧毁了不同意他们的病人和提供者的职业生涯。而一位持不同意见的分析师被他们的谣言摧毁得如此彻底，以至于他自杀了，他恳求弗洛伊德的原谅，弗洛伊德拒绝给他。
And psychoanalysis continues to get weirder and weirder for Freud's life, so does Freud. The concepts that we associate with Freud like id, ego, superego, they're kind of systematized by followers after his death even though he writes about them in ways that do survive him. He also tries to dethrone them and retcon them later after he published the things that put them in print. Freud himself never had a consistent theory. He would apply, and the point of this series is not to be a biography of him, but like he would apply one idea to every patient like Spackle and then he would abandon it for another
而心理分析在弗洛伊德的生活中继续变得越来越奇怪，弗洛伊德也是如此。我们与弗洛伊德联系在一起的概念，如本我、自我、超我，在某种程度上是由他在去世后的追随者系统化的，尽管他以确实在他死后幸存下来的方式写了关于它们的内容。他也试图在发表了将它们付诸印刷的东西后，后来推翻它们并重新设定它们。弗洛伊德本人从未有过一致的理论。他会应用，这个系列的重点不是成为他的传记，但就像他会把一个想法应用到每个病人身上，像腻子一样，然后他会为了另一个而放弃它
and he would rewrite old cases with completely dissenting opinions with himself but he wouldn't admit error. Take like little Hans in 1909 which is a five-year-old who had a fear of horses and you know he saw a horse like trample his master or rider, owner, I don't know you call people that have horses whatever, trample a guy in the street. It's sort of normal that like a five-year-old would be afraid of seeing an animal that can kill you like almost kill a guy. You may not need to dig terribly deep under the hood to figure out what's going on there. Freud's analysis is that this boy wants to kill his father and then have sex with his own mother and the horse represents his dad because it has like a hair that looks like his dad's mustache.
他会用与自己完全不同的意见重写旧案例，但他不会承认错误。以1909年的小汉斯为例，这是一个五岁的孩子，他害怕马，你知道，他看到一匹马像践踏他的主人或骑手、主人，我不知道你叫那些有马的人什么，践踏街上的一个人。五岁的孩子害怕看到一只可以杀死你的动物，就像差点杀死一个人一样，这很正常。你可能不需要在引擎盖下挖得太深就能弄清楚那里发生了什么。弗洛伊德的分析是，这个男孩想杀死他的父亲，然后与他自己的母亲发生性关系，而马代表了他的爸爸，因为它有一根看起来像他爸爸胡子的毛。
I don't know what a horse mustache looks like his dad's mustache. I don't know what a horse mustache looks like or what this guy looked like. Those records don't survive. And when Hans saw the horse fall he starts to fear his own castration because he thinks his spiritually, even though he's not under threat of that, his balls might be removed because horses lose their penises when they are castrated and the kid knows this at five and this symbolizes punishment anxiety because he wants his mom so much is the way that Freud wants to attempt to cure of a five-year-old. So horses are everywhere in 1909 Vienna. They're big, they're loud, they fall down, they're terrifying to small children, but for Freud it must be about wanting to be your mom.
我不知道马胡子看起来像他爸爸的胡子。我不知道马胡子看起来像什么，或者这个人看起来像什么。那些记录没有保存下来。当汉斯看到马倒下时，他开始害怕自己的阉割，因为他认为他在精神上，尽管他没有受到那种威胁，他的睾丸可能会被切除，因为马在被阉割时会失去阴茎，而孩子在五岁时就知道这一点，这象征着惩罚焦虑，因为他太想要他的妈妈了，这是弗洛伊德想要尝试治愈一个五岁孩子的方式。所以马在1909年的维也纳随处可见。它们很大，很吵，它们倒下，它们对小孩子来说很可怕，但对弗洛伊德来说，这一定是因为想要成为你的妈妈。
I don't like horses myself much, not because my parents. That's not really how psychology works. I just don't get it. If you like horses that's fine. But this is stupid. It's unintuitive, it's unscientific, and unlike, you know, mysticism or something, nobody feels better after they do it, you know? Like if you go to a drum circle, even like you at least feel better, you typically don't when somebody tells you that like your anxiety is being caused by you wanting to have sex with your mom because the horse reminds you of
我自己不太喜欢马，不是因为我的父母。心理学不是那样工作的。我只是不明白。如果你喜欢马，那很好。但这很愚蠢。它是不直观的，它是非科学的，而且不像，你知道，神秘主义或类似的东西，没有人做完后感觉更好，你知道？就像如果你去参加一个鼓圈，即使像你至少感觉更好，当你被告知你的焦虑是因为你想和你的妈妈发生性关系，因为马让你想起了时，你通常不会感觉更好
Your penis somehow via your dad, but also your actual penis and whatever read the case study The the post Freudians who build the actual like therapeutic approaches They like have this weird loyalty to Freud They largely still hang out in New York or or they're psychiatrists that scatter from New York that are still practicing psychoanalysis, or like 80 years old. But when you try and proy it out to them, that nothing that Freud did actually informed what the better post-Freudians did. Like people like Karen Horni, or Win Winnicott or like Bowlby like
你的阴茎以某种方式通过你父亲，但也包括你真实的阴茎，以及任何阅读过案例研究的人。那些建立实际治疗方法的后弗洛伊德主义者，他们对弗洛伊德有一种奇怪的忠诚。他们大多仍然待在纽约，或者是从纽约分散开来、仍在从事精神分析的心理医生，或者已经80岁了。但当你试图向他们探究时，会发现弗洛伊德所做的一切实际上并没有为更好的后弗洛伊德主义者提供参考。比如像卡伦·霍妮、温尼科特或鲍尔比这样的人
psychodynamic therapists then they actually were at tension with him picking things that are built more on like relationships and that like any time that Freud was even aware of them during his lifetime he hated them then they tell you that that's wrong even though like that is wrong, like he did. We have those letters. And also they also will sometimes try and get around it by treating into like retreating into like Lacan and saying Lacanian psychoanalysis or something which becomes its own thing. None of this really solves the problem of like Freudianism in America not really having anything to do with Freud.
动力学治疗师，他们实际上与他存在紧张关系，选择那些更多建立在人际关系基础上的东西。而且每当弗洛伊德在世时意识到这些，他都会讨厌他们，然后他们会告诉你那是错的，尽管那确实是错的，他是讨厌他们。我们有那些信件。而且他们有时也会试图通过退回到拉康那里来绕过这个问题，说拉康派精神分析之类的，这本身就成了另一回事。这些都无法真正解决美国弗洛伊德主义与弗洛伊德本人毫无关系的问题。
By the time that Freud is in New York, like, he's given up pretending. In one case he needs, like, funding for his institute, so he goes to his patient Horace Frank and he tells the patient to leave his wife because, like, this other female patient who's like really wealthy is like more suggestible and then she also has to leave her husband so these people can get married because the only problem with their partners from Freud's mind is that like they don't like him and they also like aren't in this secret society of Freudian patients slash providers so he tells two people to get divorced and then marry so that they can like donate to his Institute
当弗洛伊德在纽约时，他已经放弃了伪装。有一次，他需要为他的研究所筹集资金，于是他去找他的病人霍勒斯·弗兰克，告诉病人离开他的妻子，因为另一个非常富有、更容易受暗示的女病人也必须离开她的丈夫，这样这些人就可以结婚。因为在弗洛伊德看来，他们与伴侣之间唯一的问题是伴侣不喜欢他，而且他们也不在这个由弗洛伊德的病人兼提供者组成的秘密社团中，所以他告诉两个人离婚并结婚，这样他们就可以捐款给他的研究所。
but when Frank resists, Freud tells him that like he has to do it because if he doesn't he'll become like latently homosexual in Freud's words and that will make him go psychotic and the guy's, I'm not gay though. And Freud's like, yes, you aren't aware that you're gay, but it's because you're not just gay. You're like triple secret super gay. And you're so secretly gay that you don't even know you are. And that's about to make you go crazy. If you don't divorce your wife and marry this other woman, neither of which is a man, and then give me money and the manipulation works. The guilt drives Frank psychotic because his wife, it doesn't end well for her, and he dies in his like
但当弗兰克反抗时，弗洛伊德告诉他，他必须这样做，因为如果不这样做，他就会变成弗洛伊德所说的潜在同性恋，那会让他精神错乱。那个人说，但我不是同性恋。弗洛伊德说，是的，你没有意识到你是同性恋，但那是因为你不仅仅是同性恋。你是三重秘密超级同性恋。你如此秘密地是同性恋，以至于你自己都不知道。如果你不和你妻子离婚并娶这个女人（她们都不是男人），然后给我钱，这就要让你发疯了。这种操纵奏效了。内疚感让弗兰克精神错乱，因为他的妻子，这对她来说结局并不好，他死在自己的
bathtub believing that it's a grave and that his wife is a pig. Like he does become psychotic because a lot of the things that Freud kicks off. it's a grave and that his wife is a pig like he does become psychotic because a lot of the things that Freud kicks off there's a billion other stories here again the point is not to be a biography of Freud It's just sort of Explicate the things that psychotherapy is reacting to and the people that are reacting to the same culture that Psychotherapy and habits starting with this person in the first episode By the end, you know Freud tells Theodor Reich in a letter, we do analysis for two reasons, to understand the unconscious and to get
浴缸里，认为那是一个坟墓，他的妻子是一头猪。他确实变得精神错乱，因为弗洛伊德引发的很多事情。这里还有十亿个其他故事，再次强调，重点不是要写弗洛伊德的传记，只是为了阐明心理治疗所回应的事物，以及那些回应心理治疗所处的同一文化的人，从第一集里的这个人开始。到最后，你知道弗洛伊德在信中告诉西奥多·赖克，我们做分析有两个原因，了解潜意识和获得
paid. And then later, Freud writes for Krenze, patients are a rappel, only good to provide us with a livelihood and material to learn from. So at the end of his life, Freud basically says, I'm not wrong, psychoanalysis is right, it just doesn't heal anybody, and patients are like pitiful sources of money that are beyond help. Our job is to get them to pay us so that we can hear their problems, but that's just so that we can know how right we are, not really so that we can help anybody, and that because psychoanalysis doesn't work isn't really a fault of psychoanalysis, it's somehow the fault of other people.
报酬。后来，弗洛伊德写信给克伦泽，病人是垃圾，只适合为我们提供生计和学习材料。所以在生命尽头，弗洛伊德基本上说，我没有错，精神分析是对的，它只是治不好任何人，病人是无可救药的可怜的钱财来源。我们的工作是让他们付钱给我们，这样我们才能听他们的问题，但这只是为了让我们知道我们有多正确，而不是为了帮助任何人。而且精神分析不起作用并不是精神分析的错，在某种程度上是其他人的错。
And Freud's real discovery is that the unconscious exists, and it's this realm of trauma and drives and archetypes and intuitive creativity, all these things that he would never really flesh out in a coherent way or make a useful metaphor from. But he could only see sex and aggression as the thing that lay dormant under society because Freudian psychology became very good at describing Freud's own psychology, where there was a repressed obsession with sex, which we haven't gotten into. Freud probably has an affair with his wife's sister due to some recent things that came out on a hotel ledger and a scholarship that weren't available to biographers like Peter Gay that wrote pretty comprehensive biographers earlier. There's newer things now. But all of these things laid repressed in him and
弗洛伊德真正的发现是潜意识的存在，它是创伤、驱动力、原型和直觉创造力的领域，所有这些他从未以连贯的方式充实或从中做出有用的隐喻。但他只能将性和攻击性视为潜伏在社会之下的东西，因为弗洛伊德心理学非常擅长描述弗洛伊德自己的心理，那里有一种被压抑的性痴迷，我们还没有深入探讨。弗洛伊德可能与他妻子的妹妹有染，这是基于最近在酒店账本和奖学金中发现的一些东西，这些资料对于像彼得·盖这样早期撰写相当全面传记的传记作者来说是不可用的。现在有了更新的东西。但所有这些东西都在他内心被压抑着，并且
he was sort of telling everyone else that they were the source of their own misery while he was being miserable. Murray Stein says pretty coherently in maps of meaning or Jung, his book on Jung, he says Freud mistook mechanism for meaning. Freud couldn't really see or face his own trauma, so he projects it on everyone else, first as a son seeking to overthrow inadequate fathers, and then as a father defending against imaginary death wishes, and finally as a King Lear type figure with his golden rings who's playing God with human minds, and all of Vienna's intelligentsia was exploring the unconscious. Like what Freud says is not
他有点在告诉其他人，他们是自己痛苦的根源，而他自己却很痛苦。默里·斯坦在《意义的地图》或关于荣格的书《荣格》中非常连贯地说，弗洛伊德把机制误认为是意义。弗洛伊德无法真正面对自己的创伤，所以他把它投射到每个人身上，首先作为一个寻求推翻不称职父亲的儿子，然后作为一个防御想象中死亡愿望的父亲，最后作为一个带着金戒指、玩弄人类心灵的李尔王式人物。维也纳所有的知识分子都在探索潜意识。弗洛伊德所说的并不是
particularly original of an idea for the time. It is more so that Freud brings it into neurology, which would later become psychology or psychiatry and he does it in a way that is compelling because he is a good salesman, he's a good writer. But Clem, S.H.I.E.L., K.K.A.S.H.K.A. like all of these people like the artists, the theosophists, we're doing this through mysticism but like all of these people were talking about the forces of emotion that are underneath humanity, that move the world, that we can't see, that create wars and sexuality, and like all of the things that move humans along. Like it wasn't, that was not terribly original.
当时特别原创的想法。更多的是弗洛伊德将其引入神经学，后来成为心理学或精神医学，他以一种引人注目的方式做到这一点，因为他是一个好的推销员，一个好的作家。但克莱姆、希尔、卡什卡，所有这些人，像艺术家、神智学者，都在通过神秘主义做这件事，但所有这些人都在谈论人类之下、推动世界、我们看不见、创造战争和性欲的各种情感力量，以及所有推动人类前进的事物。这并不是，那并不算太原创。
Freud's ideas were interesting, but they were just wrong because he saw Darwin, he saw natural selection, he saw those things that came from sexuality and so he thought that the entire mind could be reduced back to a sexual selective mechanism. When what really happens in the mind is that there are vast layers that are much more modern and even though some of these behaviors or some of these psychic attributes maybe originally started as, or the precursors to them originally started as ways to have babies so that you can pass your genes on without dying There were much more complicated layers to humanity that had to do with relational memory that had to do with time which had to do with transcendence which had to do with
弗洛伊德的想法很有趣，但它们就是错了，因为他看到了达尔文，看到了自然选择，看到了那些源于性的东西，所以他认为整个心灵可以还原为一种性选择机制。而心灵中真正发生的是，存在着非常现代的广阔层面，即使其中一些行为或心理属性最初可能作为，或者它们的先驱最初作为生孩子的方式，以便你可以在不死亡的情况下传递基因。人类还有更复杂的层面，与关系记忆有关，与时间有关，与超越有关，与
concepts that were inborn and not necessarily learned that Freud missed because everything had to be that society was ignoring sex and that sex is actually like the force that moves everything and aggression too, which is in Freud's mind inseparable from sex because aggression is what lets you kill the person who wants to have sex with the person you want to have sex with so they're always the same, which again is not right. But unable to distinguish his own trauma from universal truth, his own mind from a greater psychology, Freud
天生而非后天习得的概念有关，弗洛伊德错过了这些，因为一切都必须是社会忽视了性，而性实际上是推动一切的力量，攻击性也是如此，在弗洛伊德看来，攻击性与性是不可分割的，因为攻击性让你能够杀死那个想和你想要发生性关系的人发生性关系的人，所以它们总是相同的，这再次是不对的。但无法将自己的创伤与普遍真理区分开来，无法将自己的心灵与更大的心理学区分开来，弗洛伊德
sort of tries to indict everyone else with the problem that he could have healed and faced himself if he wanted to be more whole. And so because he's too afraid to face what is uniquely his versus what is... he can't see what is uniquely human or fundamentally human. And that's scary because it's easier to pretend that everyone's running from your demons than that you are. And every biography at the end is a tragedy. Freud dies, he failed to heal the very wound that drove him to create psychoanalysis, the profession would take over 200 years to recover if it ever did, and then we
试图指责其他人，而如果他想变得更完整，他本可以治愈并面对这些问题。因为他太害怕面对什么是他独有的，什么是……他看不出什么是人类独有的或根本上属于人类的。这很可怕，因为假装每个人都在逃避你的恶魔比承认你自己逃避更容易。每一部传记的结尾都是一场悲剧。弗洛伊德去世了，他未能治愈那个驱使他创造精神分析的伤口，这个职业需要200多年才能恢复，如果它真的能恢复的话，然后我们
deal with our own trauma or we project it into family politics or our own patients. And right now as a society we are deciding, will we deal with it? I often wonder though if Freud felt at the end of his life in his quietest moments, if he was running from the same thing that his father had. Instead of being laying on the street, being beaten, he was pretending that he was the one doing the beating. There's an undercurrent of shame, of rage, of grief, of vulnerability, and of victimhood that Freud's writing never moves past, because Freud himself never moved past it. And to be fair, I don't know that the West moved past it even today. One of the essential ingredients in being an abusive person who justifies that abuse
处理我们自己的创伤，或者我们把它投射到家庭政治或我们自己的病人身上。现在作为一个社会，我们正在决定，我们会处理它吗？但我经常想，如果弗洛伊德在生命尽头最安静的时刻，是否感到他在逃避他父亲所拥有的同样的东西。他没有躺在街上被殴打，而是假装自己是那个施暴者。弗洛伊德的写作中有一种羞耻、愤怒、悲伤、脆弱和受害者心态的暗流，从未超越，因为弗洛伊德本人从未超越它。公平地说，我不知道西方即使在今天是否超越了它。成为一个为虐待辩护的虐待者的基本要素之一
is a belief in your own victimhood and in a certain way as Adler would diagnose after he left Freud there is a tension of these opposites. There is a big internal part for every large internal part. All of Freud's abuses of power and manipulations were justified by his own belief in victimhood. His own belief in his own ultimate victimhood that no one else could his own ultimate victimhood, that no one else could know as much as he knew because no one else could hurt as much as he was hurting. This is something that is still very much alive in the West, this ambivalence between even though I'm hurting you, you hurt me more, even though I'm the group that has all of the power, you somehow have a shadowy network beneath the scenes. The way that we deflect as the collective
是对自己受害者身份的信仰，在某种程度上，正如阿德勒在离开弗洛伊德后所诊断的那样，存在着这些对立面的紧张关系。每一个巨大的内在部分都有一个巨大的内在部分。弗洛伊德所有的权力滥用和操纵都由他对自己受害者身份的信仰所证明。他对自己最终受害者身份的信仰，没有人能像他那样了解，因为没有人能像他那样受到伤害。这是在西方仍然非常活跃的东西，这种矛盾心理，即使我在伤害你，你伤害我更多，即使我是拥有所有权力的群体，你不知何故在幕后有一个阴暗的网络。我们作为集体进行偏转的方式
is also the way that we deflect as the individual. Blame shifting. Oh, you're the one that caused me to do that. Gaslighting. Oh, you don't understand how all of these things fit together in the way that I do. Changing the subject. Oh, well, yeah, that is completely irrelevant
也是我们作为个人进行偏转的方式。推卸责任。哦，是你导致我那样做的。煤气灯效应。哦，你不明白所有这些事情是如何像我这样结合在一起的。转移话题。哦，好吧，那完全无关紧要
when we consider something that is totally different. Minimizing their behavior. Oh, well, how could you say that to me unless you are perfect? How can I apologize for this thing that I did wrong unless you apologize for everything that you've also done wrong because for some reason, your complete insight is a condition of my accountability? Victim's stance.
当我们考虑完全不同的事情时。最小化他们的行为。哦，好吧，你怎么能那样对我说话，除非你是完美的？我怎么能为我做错的事情道歉，除非你也为你做错的所有事情道歉，因为出于某种原因，你完全的洞察力是我承担责任的前提？受害者姿态。
Well, there's no one on earth that understands where I'm coming from because I'm the only person who's coming from this place of complete power and also complete powerlessness at the same time. Aren't I so smart and helpless? Over-intellectualization and rationalization. I'm not even gonna explain that one. Silent treatment, stonewalling, ghosting, sarcasm or humor, idealization or devaluation, splitting. Well, this one group is completely bad because there's something that they did wrong and
好吧，世界上没有人理解我的处境，因为我是唯一一个同时处于这种完全权力和完全无力感的人。我不是很聪明又很无助吗？过度理智化和合理化。我甚至不想解释那个。冷暴力、阻碍、断联、讽刺或幽默、理想化或贬低、分裂。好吧，这个群体完全是坏的，因为他们做错了某事，
therefore that makes me completely good and always blameless. Projection. Not even gonna explain that one either. Maybe a lot of the systems that run the modern world make all of us feel a little bit like Freud's dad. Politics would continue to speak the language of Freud even though Freud was largely going to be forgotten. And I wonder if when Freud is sitting down and looking at the future and writing Moses and Monotheism, if he didn't feel a relationship to his father and realized that he was running from the same wound, even though he handled it a different way. Neither one of them ever dealt with the pain.
因此这使我完全是好的，总是无可指责的。投射。我甚至不想解释那个。也许运行现代世界的许多系统让我们所有人都感觉有点像弗洛伊德的父亲。政治将继续使用弗洛伊德的语言，尽管弗洛伊德在很大程度上将被遗忘。我想知道，当弗洛伊德坐下来展望未来并写下《摩西与一神教》时，他是否感到与他父亲的关系，并意识到他正在逃避同样的伤口，尽管他以不同的方式处理它。他们两人都没有处理过痛苦。
And even in his later works that are supposed to be reflections on his fantasies and dreams from childhood, I wonder if he wondered why he never was successful, even in them. He'd made a career telling people that they had corrupted fathers in religion, corrupted fathers in politics, corrupted fathers in bad therapy, in medical doctors, in their own families of origin. But that he was the perfect father, the one that could take them to Rome.
即使在他后期的作品中，那些应该是对他童年幻想和梦想的反思的作品，我想知道他为什么在这些作品中也从未成功。他以告诉人们他们在宗教、政治、糟糕的治疗、医生以及他们自己的原生家庭中拥有腐败的父亲为职业。但他却是完美的父亲，那个能带他们去罗马的人。
Freud would never connect the ambivalence between the need to hide from God and the need to be God. Or the desire to disappear and not have to fight with the need to fight. The inability to handle anger, whether or not we handle it in an outward way or an internal way, is the same thing. And Freud would never realize that even though he handled his phobias, his neuroses, whatever you want to call them, I would call them, an avoidance of an emotional arc, differently from his father, that he was still ruled for his entire life by the same thing. The Moses that could finally enter the promised
弗洛伊德永远不会将躲避上帝的需要与成为上帝的需要之间的矛盾联系起来。或者消失的欲望和不需要战斗的需要与战斗的需要之间的矛盾。无法处理愤怒，无论我们是以向外的方式还是内在的方式处理它，都是一回事。弗洛伊德永远不会意识到，尽管他处理恐惧症、神经症，无论你想怎么称呼它们，我会称它们为对情感弧线的回避，与他父亲的方式不同，但他一生仍然被同样的东西所统治。那个最终能进入应许之地的摩西
land. I wonder if he wondered why even in his dreams he couldn't enter Rome. And go on smiling while your landlord is pounding on the door Up on the podium, you're famous and your straw When the alarm goes off in your Ascent feeling a song There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
之地。我想知道他是否想过，为什么即使在他的梦里，他也无法进入罗马。当你的房东在敲门时，继续微笑着。在讲台上，你很有名，你的稻草。当闹钟响起时，在你的上升感中唱一首歌。这个剧集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。